if you want to you can come in and eat
as much as you can in five minutes and
run out of the door and be sick industry
and if you did that we'd probably put
you on social media but we wouldn't
complain about it one of the great
rewards of a map is the amount of trust
that it creates we design in trust by
having a whole free buffet system where
people can help themselves to unlimited
food and drinks and board games and
newspapers and amazing Wi-Fi which is
free but all that we ask in return is
that people respect the space there is
no pressure no one is asking you what
you want you can decide anytime you want
and traditional cafes they always look
at you when you order one coffee and
then you stay there longer than they
want you to they just look at you
weirdly